johnny dapp upon hearing the news he's
in he's on the other side of the pond in
the uk right he's playing his band doing
his thing he writes this i think he
tweeted it um or instagram or possibly
and put it on social media
and he wrote
six years ago my life the life of my
children the lives of those closest to
me and also the lives of the people who
for many many years have supported and
believed in me were forever changed all
in the blink of an eye false
very serious and criminal allegations
were levied at me via the media which
triggered an endless barrage of hateful
content although no charges were ever
brought against me it had already
traveled around the world twice
within a nanosecond and it had been a
seismic impact on my life and my career
depth goes on and now six years later
the jury gave me my life back i am truly
humbled scroll down if you would kelly
he then goes on to say my decision to
pursue this case knowing very well the
height
of the legal hurdles that i would be
facing and the inevitable worldwide
spectacle into my life and it has been a
spectacle was only made after
considerable thought meaning he was like
do i want to do this yeah he doesn't
need the money you don't need the money
from the very beginning the goal was
bringing this case to reveal the truth
and nothing but the truth regardless of
the outcome speaking the truth was
something that i owed to my children and
to all those who have remained steadfast
in their support of me i feel at peace
knowing that i have finally accomplished
that
i am i and i have been overwhelmed by
the outpouring of love and colossal
support and kindness from around the
world i hope that my quest to have the
truth
be told will have helped others men or
women he was very important about that
men or women who have been who have
found themselves in my situation
and in those supporting them never give
up i also hope that the position will
now return to innocent until proven
guilty
both within the courts and in the media
he's basically calling out cancel
culture right there which we'll talk
about in a second he concludes with this
i wish to acknowledge the noble work of
the judge the jurors the court staff and
the sheriffs who have sacrificed their
own time to get to this point and to my
diligent and unwavering legal team who
did an extraordinary job in helping me
to share
the truth the best is yet to come and a
new chapter has finally begun scroll
down
and then he writes in latin
veritas
perth we just lost which meant truth
never perishes truth never perishes hey
love
johnny yes [ __ ] you ever pirates of the
caribbean coming next year
promoted that let's go classy response
i'm sure that's been crafted for weeks
in advance
uh vinnie your thoughts on this response
i mean i eloquently put i mean obviously
his lawyer the lawyers obviously i mean
put out i'm pretty sure he puts his two
cents in but bro
i understand
toxic relationships i've been i've been
in
about 44 years old i've been in i've
been in a few like the the the level of
where these people are at and the
motives and the money and the fa bro you
know what you don't understand none of
us understand even if you have rich and
famous friends which we do that are out
there
you don't understand the level of this
but i and i get what you were saying
it's you know
his lawyers are probably way more
expensive and better and you know it's
it's it's a it's a kind of catch-22 but
when it comes to the character this guy
bro
i'll tell natalya and kelly this outside
bro this guy is such a g he would dress
up as jack sparrow and go on multiple
occasions to children's hospitals of
kids that had cancer bro i'll get choked
it was like just a great to get into
that this and travel around and do it
like
i feel i feel for him i understand that
the pain and stuff i went through i 100
percent believe that him and her were
drunk and probably hate each other which
i do not condone you know guys hitting
girls but dude you ever been in a moment
where she's hitting you you got to fight
her off and you got to hold it it's it's
i can't only imagine but i mean i'm i'm
team i'm team johnny and i'm just happy
that you know what i'm saying guys
finally got a [ __ ] victory bro we
finally got just one time where i even
feel weird celebrating to be like
hey johnny yeah we got it we you know
believe all women she she's hurt the
believe all women movement which kind of
shows you that you can't believe every
single yeah believe all women how i mean
that's a slippery slope right here yeah
you can't say every pizza is good
because i eat some chili pizza i love
pizza even bad pizza is good pizza
natalia do you want to respond to what
johnny had to say um i think this was
the first um
i guess
thing that he was able to put together
that really connected i guess his
audience with how he was feeling i think
this was a really good message i think
it was a great way for him to like end
the trial
um
i feel like you read this and you can
feel
somebody's sense of like peace like this
is finally done you know like this has
not affected just me it's affected my
life my family so i think it was a very
well put together message and um i think
it was a very classy way to end
his trial with what's going on